this first chart you've got you got the
bitcoin nasdaq futures 28 day rolling
correlation what is uh what is this
showing us here
yeah so uh this is technically it's like
672 hour but uh four week rolling
correlation uh at 93
0.93 so uh basically tick for tick uh
even though the scales are a little bit
different uh wherever the nasdaq goes
bitcoin goes uh essentially um you know
bitcoin
for bitcoiners is treated as a risk off
asset it's a monetary safe haven
but increasingly over 2020 2021 it's
been adopted by macro allocators
and it's treated to them as a risk-on
asset and so um you know i think there's
there's somewhat of a bigger picture
being missed but you know that's
opportunity for everybody that's that's
happily stacking away so you know if
someone wants to sell bitcoin because of
auto correlations and you know just a
volatility model right you know the vic
spikes look at every time the vix
locally spikes i believe i put the chart
in uh but every time the vix has spiked
uh if we look in like say in a big way
march of 2020 but even like local kind
of vix uh correlations right here is the
march right here is the march 2020 you
can see that big drop in uh um uh price
yeah and that's that's the big one and
then we have an even kind of a more
zoomed up version uh you can see kind of
the last two months i've basically been
every time there's been a a spike in the
vix volatility index for the s p risk
off in equities bitcoin's kind of hit
somewhat of a local bottom um or or you
know sold often in a way um and so
there's obviously its own variables in
the bitcoin market there's derivatives
uh there's its own traders that don't
even probably look good equities but for
the last two months really the the tail
of the tape has been bitcoin
is uh being treated as a as a risk-on
asset and when things go risk off
bitcoin takes a hit and so um you know
that's kind of that's where we are in
the monetization phase uh it's treated
as a check on central bank
irresponsibility and if central banks
become marginally more responsible which
the markets have kind of priced in as a
as a probability then bitcoin's gonna
gonna take a hit and that's and that's
fine and so when you think about
correlation between bitcoin and some of
these other uh nasdaq et cetera type uh
assets
is bitcoin the leading indicator or the
stocks the leading indicator like do you
have a sense for which one is leading
the other or they're just moving in
lockstep and it doesn't actually matter
they just go together
yeah funny enough i think bitcoin has
actually become more of a pure signal in
terms of like risk on risk off uh just
it seems like it's it's more of a free
market obviously uh there's there's a
lot
more capital in these equity markets and
it's like a lot of it's kind of just
auto allocated by pensions and all this
uh where they just they just need to
establish some sort of some sort of
allocation and lock it in um there's you
know tens of trillions of dollars of
assets in these equity markets where
bitcoin isn't even trillion dollar asset
and so funny enough when we saw the vix
spiking uh i believe two weeks back uh
hit like 38 and it was really bloody
monday and then the following tuesday
after uh where equities closed in the
green both times with the nasdaq down
like four and a half percent bitcoin
bought them first both of those days and
we could see like in the spot order
books that there are some huge buyers on
coinbase just happily stacking away in
in huge volumes and so what that kind of
tells me is you know the correlation is
obviously there but bitcoin is being
increasingly viewed as you know this
more pure signal of of the kind of a
check on the financial system uh and and
how unsustainable it is and so it's
almost like a leading indicator we saw
that in march of 2020 as well bitcoin
obviously is much more volatile 50 in
the day but it bottomed
two weeks before equities and it was up
40 by the time that equities ultimately
bottomed in that march uh 2020 moment so
that's kind of how i think of it going
forward is is the volatility spike done
are we going to see a liquidity crunch
in 2022 maybe and if anyone tells you
they know they they're just flying
but ultimately i think coming out of it
how the response is after some sort of
liquidity crunch uh that's where bitcoin
really takes off
got it and then when we start to think
about some of the other instruments
around bitcoin let's look at the
perpetual's funding rate uh versus kind
of like an annualized basis what are you
seeing there
yeah so uh we talked about this a lot uh
but here we actually took like an
annualized figure of it so in bitcoin
there's a couple different type of
futures instruments there's that
perpetual futures which is just a
futures contract that never expires it
just rolls over and then you have like
the quarterlies which is more in line
with like traditional commodity future
markets right like uh every three months
there's a quarterly futures expiry and
so we can take like the spread between
the current spot market and and what
that futures price is and we can have a
basis spread and so if we annualize that
we kind of get like almost a market
neutral or risk-free uh rate in the
bitcoin markets and so
uh during april that was hitting like
these really really high uh high figures
like 40 50 plus uh and those perpetual
swap markets uh basically it's kind of
this this basis between the the spot
price uh and that uh the funding
essentially keeps incentivizes uh
allocators to to remain tethered to that
spot price and so if the derivative is
trading far above the spot market
funding will be really really positive
so this is a 168 hour moving average of
that perp's funding uh and it's
annualized but basically when what you
see in in february there is that traders
were paying 100 annualized uh to long
bitcoin
right so obviously that's not
sustainable uh it kind of shows you that
these capital markets for the wild wild
west uh but for some investors it was a
really big opportunity you got paid you
know outrageous rates to just short
bitcoin and you could not even like
short it with your entire net worth you
just if you won x short bitcoin you're
holding a synthetic dollar so you could
you could harvest 50 100 annualized
yields for a week on end for just
sitting in dollar positions and so you
know we can kind of see these boom and
bust cycles and bitcoin with on chain
indicators but we can also see it uh and
kind of the sentiment cycles in the
bitcoin derivatives market and right now
uh we're basically completely muted uh
we're not we're not like severely
negative but over the last week purpose
funding has been on average negative so
what we really kind of see is it's not
derivative driven at all and actually
all kind of long speculation is has
basically been driven out over the last
two months
got it and so when you see us down uh
kind of flat do you think we have to go
super negative uh before we get any sort
of upward price movement or how do you
think about funding uh being positive or
negative in price
yeah so i mean usually in bull markets
uh
it's it's always different this time
it's different everybody longs their
longs you see the basis futures funding
it explodes upwards as everyone's just
trying to margin margin-long bitcoin
margin along crypto and during bear
markets you saw the same thing at the
bottom of the 2018 cycle um everybody
thinks bitcoin's dead it's all over you
know they're longing the absolute or
they're shorting the absolute bottom and
you see that like the perps market
drives far below the spot market and so
it's almost like uh their derivatives
are trying to like push that volleyball
underwater that's how i describe it
they're pushing a beach ball underwater
um we're naturally that spot market is
that you know gravity or physics is
gonna take over and uh we can't really
go any lower and so we're not we're not
at that total capitulation phase yet
where derivatives are are you know
driving driving us into the dirt but you
know most of that speculative air has
been kind of sucked out of the room and
so uh right now bitcoin seems to be
pretty fairly priced from a derivative
side of things uh and i think you know
depending on equity correlations uh we
can we can see some higher prices here
but that long kind of speculative
activity that we see a lot of times in
bitcoin cycles it's really not there
today which is actually a really good
sign for bulls